ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wie
ich ihnen das beibringen soll jetzt wo
sie gerade so gut gelaunt sind
ich fürchte wir müssen heute doch mal
kurz wieder über england reden ja
entschuldigung ich kann es doch nicht
ändern der exit ist schon wieder
verschoben diesmal auf den 31 oktober
auf halloween zu deutsch
hallo wen interessiert es ist es ist
alles wie immer es war alles wie immer
lastminute eu-gipfel in brüssel harter
braig sitzung gerade noch verhindert und
wenn man bedenkt freunde was da auf dem
spiel steht war die stimmung finde ich
erschreckend gut hier angela merkel
liest im internet dass sie und theresa
may den gleichen blazer tragen wir haben
dieselben jacke anschreiben gibt ja das
stimmt gibt es ja nicht steht hier also
kummer wir haben die selben jahr kann ja
ich weiß
ich sehe es ja es ging hierbei minuten
ernsthaft wie soll man diese eu noch
ernst nehmen jetzt kriegen die briten
den sogenannten flexi braig sit ja das
heißt sie können bis halloween drin
bleiben müssen aber nicht nur
presseleute ohr so einfach wie durch
fühlt flexible verlängerung nennt man
das auf englisch theresa may kriegt
sogenannte flex tensions die frage ist
nur was wir sie denn machen mit der
zusätzlichen zeit neuerdings produziert
die frau ja vor allem wunderliche
videobotschaften als britische volk
sitzt er auf seinem loriot sofa und da
hab ich nichts gemacht der welt leute
wie mich die hat gelacht haben sie schon
mal lachen gesehen bleibt für mich nur
eine frage was genau war in diesem glas
meine damen und herren
da kommen ja warum nicht den vormittag
mal gepflegt mit 0 13 ausklingen lassen
nach all dem was sie in letzter zeit
durchgemacht hat in ihrem verdammten
unterhaus
da kann man auch mal ein bisschen
verständnis habe meine damen und herren
drei jahre nach dem referendum drei
jahre danach kommt sie jetzt auf die
idee doch mal mit der opposition zu
reden toll was ist denn das für eine
regierung ein kabinettsmitglied gestern
der bbc berichtet haben dass er auch
überhaupt nicht mehr weiß was eigentlich
los ist und wie es weitergehen solle das
ist inzwischen auch eigentlich ziemlich
egal ist er hat gesagt im parlament
sitzen eigentlich nur noch lebende tote
lebende tote denn alles egal ist oder
wie wir beim zdf sagen zuschauer
und ich wette ich würde mit ihnen das
war natürlich noch lange nicht die
letzte braig sitzverschiebung theresa
may alias agentin 007 war vor dem gipfel
auf großer betteltour wissen sie unter
anderem in berlin hier super szene sagt
die kanzlerin team riesa hey du hier
hast du immer noch keinen plan fürs
austrinken aus der eu schade komm ich
zeig dir mal wieder austreten geht guck
mal einfach rausgehen
ratschlag so schon bist du draußen alles
verstanden so weit prima und genau das
macht er jetzt auch mit einem komischen
land ja schön dass ich helfen konnte
taxi
denkt mal so gewesen wäre
erst mal so gewesen wäre in wirklichkeit
hat die eu ein klares signal der
schwäche über den ärmelkanal geschickt
was sagt denn unsere bundestag heute zu
dem ganzen dreck cit chaos meinem
britischen freundinnen und freunde rufe
ich deshalb zu let's make sure this
e-mail and scenario what you must be
yourself kalender
strange mense linkspartei und europa
diese sogenannte wertegemeinschaft muss
sich endlich mal um ihre echten probleme
kümmern rechtsstaatlichkeit in ungarn
oder polen die furchtbare eu
migrationspolitik sowas und ich sage
ihnen eins aus diesen ganzen drexhage
fiasko gibt es für mich sowieso nur eine
echte lehre bei komplexen fragen und
bitte schreiben sie sich das auf das
volk fragen nie
ich meine dass erstens gibt es gibt nur
abschreckende beispiele
ich gebe ihnen ein stuttgart 21 ja
dieses legendäre milliardengrab wird
geschaufelt wegen einer volksbefragung
bei keiner dem volk gesagt hat was das
wirklich kostet zur strafe kriegen sie
eine schiefe bahn steige quasi
stuttgarts antwort auf die babyklappe
ja nie das volk fragen hier wenn pontius
pilatus damals nicht das dumme volk
gefragt hätte ob er jesus oder barabas
kreuzigen soll dann hätten wir ostern in
allen kirchen kein kreuz über malta
sondern das pflegebett in dem jesus an
altersschwäche gestorben wäre nie das
volk fragen außer natürlich zur rettung
von süßen bayerischen bienen wir kommen
vom thema ab fakt ist fakt ist wenn
theresa may ihren deal vor dem 22 mai
nicht durch britische unterhaus bringt
werden die engländer an der europawahl
teilnehmen
ein alptraum wir schalten live zu
unserem heutigen lohn und
korrespondenten ulrich von heesen ulrich
wie groß ist denn die wahrscheinlichkeit
bitte ich habe mir noch gar nicht
gefragt browser auch gar nicht die
antwort ist nein kein bock mehr auf der
exit scheiß sowas kommt halt raus nach
2000 jahren inseln inzest
ich finde alles spannender als im brett
sogar dieses langweilige foto vom
schwarzen loch
weltsensation sagen entfernt ich sag
jetzt halt noch & schwarz mit etwas
glück sagt es vielleicht bald england
ein
brüssel macht gerade einen historischen
fehler
wir waren so kurz davor die briten
loszuwerden
diese eu mietnomaden seit die dabei sind
nur extra würste und gequengel ist was
passiert wenn die an der europawahl
teilnehmen
wer versucht uns in der eu zu halten
wird es mit einem heimtückischen umland
absolut zu diese albums heimtückisch und
auf speed und was ist jetzt der
unterschied zu vorher
das ist nicht lustig wenn die mitwählen
dann schicken die garantiert ihre
schlimmsten schwachmaten nach brüssel in
der bbc läuft schon jeden abend einen
idioten casting handverlesene quartals
irre querulanten und falls ja wer mit
den eiern ist leider überqualifiziert
naja aber er von diesen theorie sehr may
hat doch der eu versprochen die werden
sich dann zurückhaltend im eu parlament
auch die oma ist doch so gut wie weg
ihre partei plan schon im putz und dann
kommt boris johnson den kann man nicht
nehmen selbst wenn der gegend kinder
rugby spielt waltz der die einfach um
wie so ein albino nasa die eu ist eine
kleine platte junge mit mond nimmt mein
gott
also mir dass soziales immer schlimmer
ja aber nicht für mich ich weine aus und
ich weiß auch schon wohin drei vorteile
absolut ruhe viel platz und keine
engländer ich komme mit ulrich vorerst
mal sagen uns mein arzt hat mir verboten
mich weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht überall
lassen ihre techniken liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt dass selbst ein beschissenes
ab
[Musik]